next sky
thank you prime minister five years ago
the then Home Secretary Sajid Javid said
he was going to make this route on
viable since then we know we've seen
tens of thousands of people in the last
five years where do you think your
predecessors went wrong why are you
different and can I also ask what does
success look like to you will you be
setting targets for where you want the
numbers to be in a year's time
so this is look not about dwelling on
the past because the situation has just
got far worse as I said in my remarks
earlier just in the last two years you
talked about when Sergeant was Home
Secretary which is in the last two years
the numbers of people crossing the
channel legally have more than
quadrupled right that is the scale of
what is happening and they're forecast
to get worse and the other thing is not
just us right so anyone who thinks this
is just a UK specific problem isn't
being straight with you this is
happening across Europe right Europe
last year saw something like 63 increase
in the numbers of illegal migrants one
of the highest numbers they've
experienced in almost a decade and
that's because globally this is a
challenge and it's only going to get
worse unless we do something novel that
we do something bold to try and stop it
and that's what our legislation today
does now you know successes are stopping
the boats success is us having a system
that people come here illegally are
returned back to their own country where
it's safe or an alternative and if we
can get that working as I'm confident
that we will be able to as we already
are with Albania we will see the numbers
come down because people will see that
it is not worth their while to risk
their lives to pay gangs thousands of
pounds for something that ends up not
what they expect and and that is the
system that we're going to deliver now
we've always said as I've said to the
questions earlier there's no one Silver
Bullet to this right so not only do we
need the legislation to be implemented
and make sure that that we can Implement
that as quickly as possible we also need
to cooperate with our allies we need to
make sure that we keep signing returns
agreements we need to step up what we're
doing on immigration enforcement as we
are and raids are increasing
dramatically so those are all the
different things that we need to do and
we're going to do all of them we're
firing on all cylinders to grip this
problem and people can judge us on our
results we've only been in this job a
few months we're already making I think
more progress than we've made in a long
time and as a result of this legislation
I think we now have something that is
very powerful we haven't done anything
like this before and it gives us the
tool that we need to implement the
system that I described and we've gone
further than anyone's gone before it's
right that we're doing that because the
situation has got far worse than it was
just two years ago but we're responding
appropriately we're responding tough
with tough measures but they are
responsible they are proportionate and
crucially they're fair but you're not
setting specific Targets in terms of the
numbers well I think you look people
will judge us on our results and as I
said we're already seeing the results
illegal migration rates up 50 since we
announced the proposals to do that with
uh Robert at the end of last year
already hundreds of people being
returned to Albania we're getting the
Asylum backlogged down as well down by 6
000 just in the last couple of months
since we've improved all the processes
there you deal with the French at the
end of last year hopefully further
cooperation to come we promise new
legislation I'm standing here today with
the Home Secretary introducing it so we
are we are continuing to deliver the
things that we said and I'm highly
confident that as we keep moving forward
people will see a big difference on this